có phía y sở giáu dụng của đào tạo hà nối với bước bỗ lịch đăng ký mượt vàng vào lất mời của năm
học hà nghị không trọng hà mi sáo hà nghị không trọng hà mi bòi trong đó thì không còn giới hạu cú bực đăng ký
theo dõi sở giáu dụng của đào tạo hà nối thì từ ngày 1 bốn cho đến ngày 1 sau tháng 2 thì các trường sẽ tổ chức cho học sinh đăng ký thưởng nghiệm trên
còn tình sinh đầu cấp tại điện trị tế át đầu cấp trong hà nối chấm gửa ové cho viên
tăng bộ dữ liệu từ nghiệm sẽ được xóa sau đó để trình bị cho đo tăng ký chính thức
chức hà mũi thức tư thì các nhà sường tiếp tục hỗ trợ học sinh đăng ký chực kinh
đông thơi thu, kiểm tra ho sơ, đăng ký sách trên tháng lưu có
tế miệm ho sơ thì sịch tự gió và cập nhật dữ liệu lên hẹn thống buồn ai
việc cấp mạng sinh và mật khẩu cho học sinh lập chỉ có kể cả tìm sinh tự gió cũng được khoảng tất trọng ra lạc này
tư nài bộn vừa tháng tư đến hẹn gửa dữ liệu tức đăng ký giữ tế bộ lập bộ dữ
tư gió mặc phụ thông công lập khó hình tức trị tình trong thề ra nài thì các em được
in fact điều trình vũn vọng nhưng phải hòa thành chức hai miế tuy ra phụ nài bộ hình tục trọng
tư năng hình tục trọng hà mi sấu sau tìm trên những vọng đã đăng tý sạc không thay đủ được
năng hòa ngình tục trọng hà mi sấu hàngình tục trọng hà mi bộ hòa hình tục trọng hà mi bộ hòa